we have just announced uh international
launch of a brand new program in
happiness studies it's a master of arts
program in happiness studies uh and we
are looking forward to great things as
we think it fits in with our mission uh
very well uh and we are are partnering
with the happiness studies academy and
putting on this program so we put
together uh this uh 30 uh 30 credit
online uh program uh that will go uh in
effect actually in the october on the
24th of october we were thrilled when um
when centenary university president
murphy and his colleagues were
willing to um
to take the leap so to speak and create
a
an academic field
out of the field of happiness which is
sorely needed in our world
when we're talking about happiness we're
talking about cultivating resilience the
ability to deal with hardships with
difficulties
and there's plenty to go around today
whether you're talking pandemic whether
you're talking war uncertainty
whether it's on the economic level and
the emotional level so we need
a
some deep thinking
and
we need some practical advice
evidence-based advice to help people
deal with difficulties with hardships
and with challenges the master's degree
in happiness studies includes classes
in
in the basic areas of happiness which
includes micro happiness as well as
macro happiness so when we talk about
micro happiness it's about individual
well-being relationship interpersonal
well-being we talk about macro we're
talking about organization national
levels of well-being wherever you look
in whatever profession
you um you identify there is a place a
very important place
for
happiness studies for the science of
well-being somebody could go through
this program and and maybe be in the hr
field
and then put on classes and workshops
and other things within their
organization but at the same time they
could be the ceo or coo and and take
this in and then spread that to the
entire organization and with other
organizations within their industry and
so forth as i see i see a lot of
opportunity uh for individuals to to be
engaged uh to to take this master's
degree program to get the certification
uh and to go forth and do great things
with